Пане Макаллістер, ви щойно повернулися з України, де ви були й на сході країни.
Як пройшла місія та, з огляду на ситуацію з російськими військами, що ви відчували?
Європарламент надіслав до України міжпартійну делегацію на три дні з двох причин.
Перша - ми хотіли зібрати інформацію на місці: що саме відбувається,
якими є настрої серед людей. Друга - ми хотіли продемонструвати
сигнал підтримки та солідарності з Україною та її громадянами
в ці непевні часи. Ми відвідали не лише Київ, але також Запоріжжя та Маріуполь.
Чи могли би ви назвати головний висновок вашої місії?
Головний висновок - це те, наскільки важливо нам, Євросоюзу,
продемонструвати єдність разом з нашими західними союзниками,
зі США, Канадою, Великобританією. Ми хочемо, щоб цей конфлікт було вирішено.
А вирішити його можна лише шляхом діалогу та дипломатії.
Тому нам треба використати всі наявні канали комунікації з Кремлем, аби знизити напругу.
Але м'яч однозначно на половині поля Росії. З боку Кремля потрібен серйозний підхід,
щоб він долучився до конструктивних перемовин. Наш головний меседж:
ми поважаємо незалежність, територіальну цілісність і суверенітет кожної країни в Європі,
включно з Україною. І це те, чого ми очікуємо і від Росії.
Але схоже, що Росія зацікавлена говорити лише зі Сполученими Штатами
про свої, як вона говорить, безпекові занепокоєння.
Тож як може бути можливим це дипломатичне рішення, якщо Росія,
схоже, не зацікавлена у ньому?
Ми готові слухати занепокоєння Росії та придивитися до її пропозицій.
Але одне має бути зрозуміло: цей підхід Кремля, що Європу чи навіть світ
можна поділити на сфери впливу, - це підхід з минулого, йому нема місця у ХХІ столітті.
А понад 100 тисяч солдатів зі стількома озброєннями уздовж російсько-українського
та білорусько-українського кордонів, звісно, є загрозою для України.
ЄС і справді зараз наголошує на своїй єдності. Проте якщо Росія все-таки нападе,
чи збережеться тоді ця єдність, щоб запровадити справді масштабні,
а не лише символічні санкції?
27 держав Євросоюзу продемонстрували дивовижну єдність,
займаючись цією кризою останніми тижнями. Я думаю, що пан Путін
та його дії навіть призвели, можливо, до ще більшої єдності і всередині ЄС,
і з нашими західними політичними партнерами, ніж раніше.
Після того, як ви побачили ситуацію в Україні зсередини, чи вважаєте ви,
що нинішній курс ЄС і Заходу є правильним, аби переконати Росію не атакувати Україну?
Я хотів би, щоб ми не були у цій складній ситуації. Але вона склалася не з вини України.
М'яч однозначно на російській половині поля. Це нарощування військ,
якого ми вже десятиліттями не бачили у таких масштабах у Європі,
є загрозою для України. Нам треба сісти разом з Кремлем і сказати:
дивіться, справи не можуть продовжуватися так, як зараз, це неприйнятно.
І давайте знайдемо шлях, як ми можемо жити в Європі у мирі та в безпеці.
І давайте поважати один одного.
Чи вважаєте ви, що постачання оборонних озброєнь Україні може допомогти
стримати Росію від подальшої агресії та посадити її за стіл переговорів?
Україна має право обороняти себе. І Україна перебуває під велетенським тиском.
Тому зрозуміло, що керівництво України попросило країн-партнерів
надати військове спорядження, оборонні озброєння. Багато країн вже надали обладнання.
Європарламент ухвалив у грудні минулого року резолюцію, де ми закликали держави ЄС
надати оборонні озброєння на запит України. Але ми знаємо,
що це суверенне рішення кожної окремої держави ЄС.
Німеччина належить до тих країн, які не вважають, що постачання зброї Україні
допоможе стримати Росію від вторгнення. Якою є ваша особиста позиція
щодо цього як німецького політика?
Німеччина підтримує Україну, наприклад шляхом надання польового шпиталю.
Питання, щоб постачала Німеччина зброю чи ні, - це політичне рішення,
яке повинно бути ухвалено всередині уряду ФРН. Особисто я вірю,
що є багато хороших аргументів на користь обмежувальної політики експорту озброєнь Німеччиною.
Це не лише пов'язано з нашою історією, але також є нашим спільним принципом.
Але були винятки з нашого принципу не постачати озброєння у райони конфліктів.
Наприклад, кілька років тому уряд Німеччини вирішив озброїти курдські загони пешмерга
для боротьби з загрозою "Ісламської держави". Тож винятки були,
і я закликаю уряд Німеччини ретельно проаналізувати запити України.
У цій серйозній і відчайдушній ситуації нам слід продемонструвати
солідарність та підтримку України. Це непросте питання, і ви знаєте,
що дебати довкола цього в Німеччині є дуже контроверсійними.
Але я завжди закликатиму уряд ФРН уважно аналізувати ці запити та,
якщо можливо, то ми маємо підтримати наших українських партнерів.
Розкажіть більше про ваші особисті враження від цієї місії.
Чи відчували ви страх, коли були в Україні?
У Маріуполі ми відвідали порт, військову базу, зустрілися з консультативною місією ЄС,
пройшли центром міста. Відвідали "Дзвін миру". Моє враження, що люди,
з якими ми говорили, дуже стурбовані ситуацією. Вони знають, що таке жити
у цій складній ситуації. У 2021 році вони стикалися з порушеннями
припинення вогню, з тим, що біля лінії розмежування щотижня гинули люди
- військові чи цивільні. З іншого боку, дивовижно, наскільки спокійно вони реагують.
Люди ходять на роботу, на закупи. Продукти доставляють. Діти ходять до школи.
Тож вони стурбовані, але вони спокійні та сповнені рішучості
захищати вільну, суверенну та незалежну Україну.
Що найбільше вразило вас під час перебування в Україні?
Те, як сприймають цю кризу. Це найбільше скупчення військ у Європі
за десятиліття. Ситуація є дуже тяжкою та тривожною. Проте ми зустріли
так багато людей, які горді бути громадянами суверенної та незалежної України.
Це дивовижно. Треба знайти вирішення цієї кризи дипломатичним шляхом.
І Євросоюз зробить усе можливе, щоб знизити напруженість
біля російсько-українського кордону.